he is the altar of the moment he is none
other than Ryan Khalil of the Carolina
Panthers how are you Ryan
I'm doing great rich are you you're
blowing up social media that's how
you're doing I know that it's what I do
I try to break the internet rich you
know that about me
so of mine well not many people can do
the OT a thing and snap the internet in
half like you've done today well done so
what let's walk us through walk me
through the genesis of your spoof video
of your quarterback that's breaking into
you yeah well we we had a we had our
annual oline cousin plus Luke Kuechly
camping trips that we've been doing for
quite some time now and we go up to the
brevard mountains group was called
chocks away so Cherokee for the place of
thunder okay so you wanted to know that
Richard so yeah so we go up there
beautiful place do couple nights camping
just the guys no cell phone service but
the the iPhone recording still works so
we thought we'd capture the clip and we
had a little inspiration from our
quarterbacks so social media and he just
you know he's got the he's got the
production value man he's got a full
team that follows him around and I don't
ever tease him about that you know you
know me I would never teach him about
his own personal photographer or
videographer but you know like like most
directors we took some inspiration from
some old footage and and really used
that to capture the moment and thus is
the product you saw well I mean Ryan
you're you're you're going out there and
saying this was done with
spit-and-polish but I I think there's
some veneer to this there's some
production value there appeared to be
some drone shots
I'd imagine from some aerials am I wrong
walk them through that yeah I mean we
had a guy had a grown out there just a
little DJI drone and we had iPhones I
mean it's just you know they get that
worldwide developer conference for Apple
this should be an ad for Apple because
it really was shot all in an iPhone and
done it pretty quickly and also
cut on the iPhone on the way back
driving back from from the mountain come
on no way you're oh yeah you're editing
on the way back home on the way back all
the way
took me all 20 minutes dead at that
thing no seriously so you're sitting
shotgun you're sitting in a back seat
and you're you're editing what what's on
your Instagram today of the split-screen
you got you got cams well shot birthday
video on the left and then the total
send up on the right I mean what do you
think he's paying that guy to do all the
videos 40 grand 50 groaning you tell me
I could have said I could have saved him
thousands of dollars if he would have
just invited me on a sweet birthday trip
but he didn't so and thus he has to pay
out of the wazoo for it I mean I mean we
we did that video we shot it in 35
minutes it was real it was literally the
end of the camp trip and it was Luke's
idea I don't want to take credit for he
can get executive producing credit can't
we Oh Kiki so we started shooting it
yeah we started shooting it shot for
shot and uh it was a good time Ryan kind
of course Olsen Olsen was the perfect
guy to to uh collapsing the rap part so
yeah he was so that was the divvying up
of the on-air I guess responsibilities
right exactly right so okay so Kuechly
is the executive producer what are you
are you the director producer what's
your credit everything else director
producer scimitar refer wardrobe and jet
location and and then Greg Olson was
best actor what we got here I mean what
category will he be importing role
supporting here I would say we tried to
split it up pretty evenly now the
question is Ryan is who broke this news
to cam did you just post it and then
just let him find it himself or did you
sit down Cameron and say this is what we
did it may or may not have been snuck
into Ron Rivera powerpoints no hold on a
minute
come on I don't use really that's what
happened at OTAs yeah
in the morning it was pretty good he had
everybody going that he was upset about
guys posting stuff on social media and
we got to be smarter and he said first I
got to deal with cams you know video
he's putting out there during OTAs and
really really old and feel bad about it
and then he's like now I got a deal with
this bs we loaded it up it's pretty
great
play corrupted no kidding no yeah not a
bit did you bust out the phone and shoot
cams reaction to this or is that on
anyone try to keep it in-house know that
I mean we try to keep something still
sacred in the locker man in the age of
post as much stuff as you can and look
at me look at me we try to every now and
then we try to keep as much of that
stuff Wow personals bosses so who's the
one who got Rivera looped in on this is
that you Ryan did gazelle yeah of course
of course yeah
now got to give them you've got to give
yourself bigger credit then just
producer-director all-around best boy
here I mean come on now that's some
serious producing I mean if you want to
give me some kind of like Rich Eisen
show award I wouldn't I wouldn't turn it
down oh sure I mean if there's some
there's some sort of like Oscar s type
you know mmm the riches for social media
videos that that should be a yearly
thing rich and I would gladly submit
videos more often to the show okay yes
the first annual Richie I guess I like
it I also like this I like that a lot
now I will value a Richie very much well
you would I would take no more
submissions I would remove all
submissions rip the knob off and hand
you the first fake currently Richie
award if you got Jerry Richardson
involved in your next video similar to
what you just shot but it's that risible
that's an automatic win that's what
you're saying it's like the Buy It Now
button hit it well you win it now you
get the Christmas you get the Chris's to
send me what a richie looks like I'll
definitely think about that done all
right Ryan I don't want to make you late
for your meetings I know you popped up
your meetings to come in and take great
credit for what you deserve which is
coach that don't tell coach that he
doesn't know I did
had to go the bathroom come on rich
watch out up here man
cats out of the bag Ryan I'm sorry to
say thanks for rising and grinding with
the show appreciate it always always
read to you guys let's do you bet that's
Ryan Khalil here on the rich on the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like some of that get
some more of that on the Rich Eisen
shell app follow all the information you
see right here on the Rich Eisen show